I was just grateful that there was a
part for play a star cross lever I love
the casting with this pair of you two
and I really like the energy with you
out tell me what it was the Disney
background that did it for you right
that's what it did it Walt loves to
bring that up but I think the the true
connection was flying through the air
you know in the air so you can't
you mean you can't know someone better
you don't know you have to physically
like trust them to catch you or to you
know not let go of you and in so and in
many ways I kind of became our bonding
experience so I think that that helped
yeah and she was like clearly cut out
for it
I knew missing something she was born to
do it was pretty evident on the first
day of it she was really pretty gets on
your next level that just got me stoned
birdie Showtime
well you said to that she was your
favorite on-screen kiss why what made
that such a good onscreen kiss well I
mean our characters go through so much
in this movie there's this unspoken kind
of relationship about it's communicated
through looks and like just proximity is
even kind of electric and at that point
in time and in the eighteen fifties that
relationship was very tab it was like
knots not it was there's something
beautiful about a love story where the
two characters can not just can't be
together but they can't communicate
not supposed to be seen together and I'm
supposed to touch your talk or whatever
because it presents danger so there's
something special about that because now
every moment where they look at each
other or where they you know so much is
just you know touching each other's
pinkie you know that was the one of the
sexiest things though for me that slight
touch that hey you know it's it's a much
much more emotional experience for them
you know there's a lot more at stake for
these characters so when the kiss
happened it's paid off because you're
waiting for it and every time you think
it's gonna happen it does it does it
exactly fortunately like just have to
deal with the real world and the times
and the things that they're living in
you know so of course it's it's it pays
off in that way yeah I agree with that
answer